north carolina congressman madison
cawthorne is again in trouble with the
law police in charlotte stopped
cawthorne at the airport yesterday after
he tried to carry a loaded handgun
through security scott mcfarland is on
capitol hill scott this isn't the first
time quattron has done that what's the
story good morning vlad this is the
second time he was stopped with a gun at
security the first time was last year at
the asheville regional airport he said
that was a mistake hawthorne is 26 years
old the youngest member of congress in
his first term but he's already had a
series of run-ins with police and with
his colleagues
we will restore the second amendment by
repealing that was republican
congressman madison cawthorne stumping
for president trump earlier this month
on tuesday police said they seized a
firearm from cawthorne at charlotte
douglas international airport the tsa
tells cbs news they recovered this
loaded nine millimeter handgun police
said cawthorne was cooperative with
officers they cited him with a
misdemeanor charge for possession of a
dangerous weapon on city property he
could face nearly fourteen thousand
dollars in fines you don't have to
apologize for your beliefs or cower to a
mob that was caught thorin before he was
elected to office in 2020. in his short
career since the congressional freshman
has been embroiled in a series of
controversies
he was charged with driving with a
revoked license in early march then
stunned his colleagues with this podcast
appearance then all of a sudden you get
invited to like hey we're going to have
kind of a
sexual get-together at one of our homes
you should come alleging that he'd been
invited to an orgy and watched members
of congress snort cocaine that drew
backlash from fellow republicans as did
comments referring to ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky as a thug
madison is wrong
if there's any thug in this world it's
putin north carolina voters even sought
to bar hawthorne from seeking reelection
arguing that his speech before the
january sixth capital riot helped incite
the violence we will be contesting the
election
a federal judge disagreed and blocked
that effort last month
we reached out to cawthorne for comment
we haven't heard back yet though his
political story is unique this incident
is not the tsa tells cbs news it seized
about 1800 guns at airport checkpoints
this year seized 6 000 last year and 86
of them were loaded
tony
a lot of people carry weapons as a
matter of habit or practice it'd be
interesting to hear uh from uh
kawhorn himself when the comment is
forthcoming scott thank you very much
for that report